[Music]
do
so
[Music]
hello hello oh i'm on
very clearly
hi everyone
we are small but we are mighty tonight
good to see you guys thanks for being
here welcome to the table
my name is karen
welcome to those of you that are here
and coming in and welcome to those of
you online thank you for
joining us on this sunday evening
i have a couple of announcements ways
that you can get connected
in the coming weeks first of all we have
our twice yearly state of the table
meeting coming up on sunday february 6th
that's what three weeks from now
right after the service
what is state of the table you might ask
well it's kind of like state of the
union only much much smaller
it's really a family meeting for anybody
that is interested in or invested in the
table and the community here we talk
about everything from our finances to
leadership transitions to our focus
areas in the coming year our goals it's
really a great way to get your finger on
the pulse of what's going on here
now and in the future for the rest of
the year so we'd love to have you join
us for that everybody is is invited to
be a part of it um
will we be streaming it online for our
okay online people it will be streamed
online so we'll give you information on
that when we get it so again sunday
february 6th it'll happen right after
the service right here in the sanctuary
uh also just a side note we will not
offer child care for that so you might
have to schedule accordingly if you have
kiddos
secondly the sunday after that which is
february 13th does anybody know what
that sunday is
super bowl yeah super bowl sunday
the super bowl starts at 5 30
which is kind of a bummer for anybody
who's a football fan who's wanting to
watch the super bowl so we are
graciously shifting the service
in the name of charity and hospitality
so you can do both you can come
join us here at the table for service at
4 pm so we're shifting an hour earlier
4 p.m to 5 p.m that gives you time to
get home and watch super bowl or
wherever you're going to watch it so
stay to the table don't forget about
that february 6th the following sunday
super bowl sunday we will get started at
4 pm instead of 5 pm
all right
cool well how about if we
take a moment to just
first of all breathe
you're here
you've tuned in the hard part is over
you've arrived take a deep breath
and let's pray before we get into the
service
god thank you for tonight thank you for
everybody
that is with us here god i pray a
blessing of peace
of calm
of hope and centering on you tonight god
and god we also
pray
your peace and your comfort over all of
those
impacted
at the synagogue in colleyville
at the congregation beth israel
god i pray
that you would give them your
peace and your presence
help them to know they're not alone
heal the trauma the terror that they've
gone through
pray your blessings over the rabbi there
god
and i pray against violence of any form
over any congregation god just pray for
your shalom your peace here on earth as
it is in heaven
so god we give you our hearts
we open ourselves up to you tonight
help us to be present
and god i pray that the music and the
words and
everything that shared here tonight
would
bring your love and your goodness
we pray all of this in jesus name amen
amen
thank you karen um we are really glad
that y'all are here to worship with us
if you feel comfortable to stand while
we sing it for me it helps me to engage
my whole body in the act of worship
rather than just taking it in kind of
like a performance
so if it's that way for you please stand
if it is somehow more meaningful for you
to focus on the lyrics to sit you are
more than welcome to do so but i do want
it to be a communal time where we're all
entering into this together i don't want
there to be a wall even though there's
this weird divider thing between the
stage and
and those seats let's just pretend like
that's gone tonight and enter in
together um my name is mindy if it's
your first time here welcome and feel
free to sing along or just take it in
all right
[Music]
let the king of my heart be the mountain
where i run
the fountain i dream from oh is my song
let the king of my heart be the shed
where i hide
the ransom for my life
is
[Music]
you are good
let the king of my heart
be the wind inside my sails
[Music]
the egg of my days
oh
you are good
[Music]
you're good
you're never gonna let me down
you're never gonna
[Music]
and you are good
oh
[Music]
is
you are good
you're good
[Music]
you are good
come
[Music]
lord
i am trusting that you are a faithful
father
[Music]
is like no other won't you come and
break through to me over and over and
over again i am bringing my heart to you
with open hands
[Music]
my
is
your love's like no other won't you come
and break through to me over and over
and over
[Music]
open again
closer and closer you're drawing me in
as the depths of my heart lay before you
again
over and over
again i am bringing my heart to you with
open hands
closer and closer you
try before you again
[Music]
come
and tear down the walls i've built up
every wall i've built up every wall i
built up cause you
deserve every piece of my heart every
piece of my heart every piece of my
heart
[Music]
cause you
deserve every piece
[Music]
yes
whatever it is that we shield ourselves
with that we protect ourselves with god
we want to
let you in
beyond that god to do your good work
your deep work in our hearts
thank you god for meeting us right where
we're at
[Music]
that nothing scares you away
there's no reason that you would run
away or forsake us
you for being here with us
we're going to enter into our prayers of
the people
um if this is your first time there's
going to be a part during the prayer
where we leave it open for
you to share a name or situation that
you're carrying on your heart
and we just believe that together as a
body that's something that we can lift
up to lift up together and share in the
burdens that we're carrying and believe
that god is going to meet us here and
that he is also shouldering those with
us that he is caring for the people that
we care about
um so please feel free to join in and
share a name or a situation and if
you're online um you may do that in the
comments as well and karen will try to
be tracking those and sharing them as
they show up so
jesus for the city of saxi texas and for
every city and community and all of
those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you've given us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick for the widow
and the orphan for the injured and the
suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and the destitute for
prisoners and captives and for all who
remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so now we lift these names
and situations up to you
chelsea
from online
please lift up robin and her family
also claire
and the new baby's safe birth
for cj as he battles coven
for the moore family
and please lift up karen paris
kelsey
[Music]
anita
johnny owen
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light healing and hope
peace
and a deep sense of your presence
amen
this is a reading from numbers chapter
6.
the lord said to moses
tell aaron and his sons
this is how you are to bless the
israelites
say to them
the lord bless you and keep you
the lord make his face shine upon you
and be gracious to you
the lord turn his face towards you
and give you peace
so they will put my name on the
israelites
and i will bless them
[Music]
lord bless
you and
keep you
make his face shine upon you and be
gracious
face
[Music]
amen
lord bless you
and
keep you
make his face shine upon you and be
gracious
[Music]
man
um
[Music]
may his favor be upon you and a thousand
generations
and your family and your children and
their children and their children may
his favor be upon
[Music]
go before
he is for you
[Music]
oh
is for you
[Music]
is
jesus thank you for every person in this
room
and every person that's with us online
and i pray god that they would feel your
presence overflowing inside of them that
they would feel your love and your
acceptance that they would feel your
forgiveness and your goodness and your
redemption
flooding into the small broken pieces of
our lives god would we see your light
and your warmth coming into our homes
into our families
our workplaces our schools
god in our relationships
would we see
you doing a new work
thank you that you're for us
that you're not against us
would we believe it down in our bones
would we live like that
not as victims
but as a whole people who are loved and
called by you
thank you jesus
thank you for your kind of love
it's in your name we pray all these
things
amen
thank you guys would you all be seated
and take a second to turn to the people
around you and say hello and make them
feel welcome
brett's going to get us started with our
message
well good evening everyone
grace and peace
my name is brett and the pastor here and
it's really great to be with you all
we uh we few
we happy few shakespeare oh my gosh
that's coming back to me from
my sophomore year of high school
um
but i think between uh the old omicron
omicron never sure how to say it and uh
in cowboy's playoff game we're a little
light tonight but
um i like it i like to be with y'all i
like um i don't know sometimes there's
something about um less people it's a
little more a little more intimate less
of a crowd almost more of a church
you know
which is a good thing at church i think
so all that to say i just want to
welcome welcome you all thank you for
being here um a huge thank you also to
the worship team that was a beautiful
set
rules
and frankly if you've read the gospels
you know they were quite frustrated at
the centers
basically the people in their nation who
weren't getting with the program
right
and now why were they so passionate
about this this is where nt wright
speculates it's because
if if people would get with the program
if the people would clean their lives up
if we'd obey the laws and listen to god
and obey again then what would happen
the fire
the fire would fall
the glory would dwell again
then
then god would kick out these roman
oppressors because the persians were
replaced later by the romans you know
it's kind of the march of history
they'd kick out these roman oppressors
and the fire would fall and then we'd
we'd be back to how it's supposed to be
right where the presence of god is like
here among us and this by the time you
get to the new testament by the time you
get to jesus this was just very much the
sense kind of in judaism at that time
like on the one hand hey the second
temple
um
you know i mean it's there
and and yet there was this sense that
like man it's just not quite like it was
like jerusalem you know where there's
just not quite what it was there's um
you have the romans still in town
oppressing the people and technically in
charge um even though they let the
people live in the land but they were
oppressing them um you have even the
temple itself
it just wasn't what it used to be like
not only was it less kind of glorious
and just beautiful to structure itself
because they just didn't have the money
and the people power of like in the old
days
but um even jesus right if you remember
there's a moment where jesus clears the
temple
remember that he this is the second
temple he walks in that second temple
and he drives out all the money changers
and all the right and what is going on
well apparently
we can kind of get a hint at what it
what was going on by the what does jesus
say like you've you've turned what's
supposed to be a house of prayer
you've turned it into a den of thieves
and robbers
right and that was jesus wasn't alone in
that condemnation like that was kind of
the sense at that time among the people
like this just
no fire
no glory
so fast forward to acts chapter 2. now
we're in the new testament
this is the beginning of the early
church this is after the life the death
the resurrection of jesus but before his
ascension
and
he told his disciples he said i'm about
to ascend to the father i'm going to
leave but i don't want you to leave
i don't want you to leave i want you to
stay i want you to receive the gift that
my father promised you
god promised you
the holy spirit i want you to stay here
in jerusalem
and so jesus ascends to the father and
what do they do they stay they wait
they go to an upper room they're just
waiting
acts chapter 2
verse 1 when the day of pentecost came
they were all together in one place
suddenly a sound like the blowing of a
violent wind came from heaven and filled
the whole house where they were sitting
and they saw
what seemed to be
tongues
of fire
that separated and came to rest on each
of them
and all of them
were filled with the holy spirit
and they began to speak in other tongues
as the spirit
enabled
them
what just happened
the fire fell
the glory of the lord
came again
but notice
where did it fall
we might say who did it fall upon notice
it wasn't the temple in jerusalem
which by the way was there like just
down the road
who did it fall upon
it came upon
people
in fact
the writer of our text peter
he was there
in that room
and
he actually i mean he had a front row
seat like to this experience back not
just a front row seat but like he
actually
experienced it
like the fire the glory of the lord like
fell on him but not just him and not
just the disciples but like all of the
early believers gathered there's about
70 people
like he was there and this is why as we
come to first peter chapter
this is why he says that god is building
a temple
but it is not a temple built of cold
hard stone
with human hands well what is it it's a
temple of human hearts and minds and
lives
god is building a temple
but
he's building
us
his spirit is falling upon us
i love the children they're doing their
little chants
so sweet
it's so hard
all the people on the podcast are like
what is he talking about we don't hear
anything
well
it's one of the benefits to being in
person
um
but you know what um so we are living
stones we're being placed into this
beautiful
building so to speak that god is is
building um
but who's the cornerstone
right who's the most important stone um
it's not you or i
um
of course peter says it's jesus
and the cornerstone like i kind of
referenced earlier the romans when they
would eventually even destroy that
second temple um
this is why they couldn't destroy that
because it the cornerstone
of buildings in the ancient world at
least for big buildings was i mean y'all
ridiculous huge i mean imagine a stone
as long as this sanctuary like what i
mean could be you know 75 feet 100 feet
um
you know 10 feet wide i mean these would
be 10 000 tons i mean huge stones and
basically what they did when they chose
the cornerstone was it had to um be
flawless right no cracks because the way
they built in the ancient world
basically the cornerstone had to sustain
the weight of the entire structure
as well as set the lines for the whole
building
so it had to be straight and true
right
and this becomes i mean just a beautiful
picture this is why he says like jesus
is our cornerstone what's he saying like
jesus um is the perfect image and
representation of god i mean if you have
to build a people if you have to build a
new temple like who do you want to build
it on what kind of a life
right who's going to be the foundation
the the um
yeah that's what's going to hold that
structure and he says it's jesus right
the god who is love
the perfect image and representation of
god that he points out the builders
rejected right because builders in the
ancient world would often reject
cornerstones because they're like not
good enough not good enough not right
because you need the awesome stone you
need like the the last thing they need
is to spend you know 100 years building
a structure and then crack the
cornerstone breaks like nope so they
would often reject stones and of course
if you know the story of christ
crucifixion
the stone the builders rejected
has become the chief stone the corner
stone
in other words peter is saying god is
building a people and he starts with
jesus he starts the cornerstone but then
each and every single one of us
are being placed like living stones into
the
beautiful structure that god is building
in other words church
you are the temple
the place where god dwells
that's the message tonight
you are the temple
the place where god dwells first peter 2
5. you also like living stones are being
built into a spiritual
house
because of course a temple like this is
the place where god dwells
so if you are the temple right think
acts chapter 2 the fire fell upon people
um now you are the place where god
dwells which means everywhere you go
the spirit of the living god goes to
which leads to peter's second insight if
you are the temple well he says not only
are you the temple um he says you are
the priest
what's a priest a bridge from god to a
hurting world
you are the priest a bridge from god to
the hurting world verse five again you
also like living stones are being built
into a spiritual house to be a holy
priesthood
you might say well brett i thought uh i
thought you were the priest or the
pastor or the
don't you have to go to seminary to be a
priest
um peter doesn't think so
no he says you
you are the priests
you are the bridge from god to a hurting
world which means again everywhere you
go the spirit of the god of the living
god goes to and what's fascinating is i
was thinking this week like what's
something mundane like that means when
you for example you go to
walmart
right so um
william goes to walmart maybe i don't
know maybe william doesn't go to walmart
let's just say for the sake of this
sermon i need you to go to walmart okay
william goes to walmart
will
marissa linda right goes to walmart
and it's easy to just go to walmart and
just be you like oh here i am
and yet what is the implication of this
teaching
that when you go to walmart you're not
just at walmart as you
like you're there with the eyes of a
priest
you're there asking
who
needs a smile
who needs encouragement
who who needs maybe even a prayer
i mean maybe you feel prompted to like
pray for someone like can i pray for you
you know don't do that too often make
sure it's not just i don't know ego
getting in there like i gotta pray for
all these people they need to touch from
the spirit you know it's like okay be
careful that but i do i will say though
i'm not trying to shoot that down there
is a time and a place for that often
though it's probably just gonna be quiet
okay just
bring some balance to this teaching um
right but but that's the idea like you
go there um with the eyes of the priest
asking like god so i'm here as your
ambassador
what do what do they need
what does every person i interact with
at school at work in my family like
like in other words um
it's it's about really you know being so
available i have a friend who's often
been this for me
he's been
a priest he's
um he's not like technically you know a
pastor priest in the modern sense that
we would think of it but he's a musician
artist
and he's also a very good question asker
and more than one time i've like hadn't
been in a conversation with him
and um i'll just give like i don't know
like a throwaway line you know of
something like oh man i can never do
that
and he's like oh really why why not he
starts asking these questions and like
uh
and he's like why why do you say that
it's like oh i mean
it's just not really my
my gift just even the idea that starts
to give me anxiety you know and he's
like well that's interesting i mean
maybe yeah maybe not but
i don't know i think you could do it
do you do you like do you think it's
really not your call or are you just
deeply afraid of that thing and like all
of a sudden i'm like starting to feel
emotional i'm like oh what is going like
this is turning it into a god moment
right what's what happened well i
thought i was just talking with my
friend
but suddenly i realized oh wait a second
i'm talking with a priest
i'm talking with someone who's bridging
me
to god right are you tracking with me
like
and unless you think you know that this
means so every conversation must be
incredibly intense really um let me kind
of boil it down to this if you're taking
notes you can write this down i'm really
just saying like be present
be
available and look for the god moments
that's really what i'm saying be present
be available look for the god moments
because they're happening
they're happening
third
you are the sacrifice
a life of worship love and service like
this took a dark turn i'm the son i'm
the i like being the temple and the
priest i'm not sure about the
about being the sacrifice
of this is what he says back to verse
five you also like living stones are
being built into a spiritual house to be
a holy priesthood offering
spiritual
sacrifices acceptable to god through
jesus christ
so just to be clear god does not desire
the blood of lambs and goats
what he desires is a life
lived
beautifully
a life of obedience
of prayer
worship
love
service
compassion
forgiveness
reconciliation boy doesn't doesn't our
world need this
don't our communities
need this like rowlett saxey wiley plano
richardson
i mean
for instance like
your our places of work your family
like
we need
beautiful lives
sacrificial lives
and not in a killjoy way like well i've
got to be a sacrifice for the lord you
know
like no no no it's
full of joy isn't that what jesus said
if you want to gain your life you got to
lose it
you gotta let it go
and be of service
and say god anything you want
anything you want lord why because
i'm the temple and the priest and the
sacrifice
so let's do it
let's live into it
you bow your heads close your eyes let
me pray for you
lord jesus
so often
um we we discount ourselves
we think
that you will use other people
more spiritual people more mature people
holy people priestly people
and yet your word has come to us today
reminding us that in fact we are the
temple
we are the priests we are the sacrifice
and so our prayer is make us good ones
make us faithful ones
make us a community where your fire has
fallen
where your glory dwells
in the name of the father the son and
holy spirit
amen
um in light of everything brett just
shared why don't you guys just stay
seated for this last song and just take
some time
um it's a beautiful song by a band named
the brilliance
and i highly recommend looking them up
if you're looking for some new music but
this song has just been one that has
really
been like a holy moment for me every
time i hear it it just is like one of
those
times where it's like yeah i want to be
that i want to be that priest i want to
be i want to have those eyes of jesus
that that are bringing the light and the
love
um
to a hurting world so just reflect take
it in enjoy jesse's
[Music]
we know so much
headline breaks
and we start to hate again
[Music]
calling them names again
i hope we believe
[Music]
day by day
there is
[Music]
is
i hope we believe
[Music]
it's see
alone
[Music]
see
is all around you
is all about
[Music]
thanks you guys that was beautiful
thank you for being here with us tonight
here and online i hope that this service
blessed your heart you deserve it uh
just a couple reminders
um you are not alone in whatever you're
going through so please uh if you'd like
some prayer after the service just come
up and find me i'd be happy to pray with
you
secondly if you're visiting with us
tonight or if you even have a prayer
request that you don't want to talk to
anybody about tonight we have a visitor
cards and prayer request cards they're
right outside the door on a little tiny
table
tiny with a little wooden box
so grab a card there's a pen there
please write your name and contact
information uh help us to stay in touch
with you we'd love that
and then lastly i'd like to leave you
with a benediction and so if you're
comfortable doing so please stand to
your feet
hold out your hands and a posture to
receive this for yourself
this is for each one of you
here and online
[Music]
and
if you've ever felt like you're outside
the reach of god's love
or grace
this is especially for you tonight
you are a child of god
you
are a child
of god
this is true on your best day
and on your worst day
so as you go into the week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted
just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
gifts
of unconditional love and grace to
everyone you come in contact with
be blessed have a great week ahead
and we hope to see you back here next
sunday good night
you